okay we're gonna have open phones next
hour with bob chapman and i'm gonna go
over a wide spectrum of news oil set to
go up to a hundred dollars a barrel
we told you so three months ago we're
gonna get lindsey williams back on next
week by the way uh we're going to get
into mexican gunman fires across the
border towards u.s highway workers i see
this kind of stuff every week but the
media is playing it down
we're also going to get into a report
out of afp freedom is in decline
worldwide u.s report states
so our own government's admitting
freedom is plunging worldwide but
talking about other countries what about
here
so that's all coming up as well but open
phones at 800.25 at nine ninety two
thirty one well dr wallach i appreciate
you coming on while you're out on the
road i look forward when you're back in
the office in the next few weeks uh
getting you on the broadcast
and uh absolutely uh
i hope people get involved in this
because i only promote and push what i
believe in and what i think will help
people
and folks can judge by our track record
if i have good judgment
but people make their own judgment um i
am going to start on the regimen of the
basic products you've developed that are
mineral and vitamin based and all
natural uh because it's full spectrum
and i've done the research and you're
the only organization or group that i've
found that that fits in with the
separate research i've done
uh and what i learned working for
a veterinarian
and of course you are a veterinarian but
also a naturopathic nd
and so the website is infowars
team.com and i'm flattered that you guys
even created me my own website uh for
this that hooks into your great uh
website uh so again and they've got
great discounts there and it is ten
bucks you sign up as a membership and
then you can also sell the products to
others uh and uh this is all about the
products uh just absolutely amazing
there's quite a few of them up there on
the site at infowarsteam.com
and the time we have left uh dr joel
wallick
other key tidbits other things that
mineral and vitamin and trace element
deficiencies are triggering and causing
i know it's not just hair falling out in
gray hair and bad fingernails and bad
skin and you know on the inside it's
causing problems isn't it
yeah sure exactly right when you have
gray hair you're also getting a
breakdown of the elastic fibers your
arteries and your blood vessels you're
going to get spider veins varicose veins
hemorrhoids ruptured aneurysms
uh even
albert einstein died at age 76 of a
ruptured aortic aneurysm which is a
simple copper deficiency and of course
it also causes white hair which he was
legendary for
and then you can also you're going to
get with the deficiencies of these trace
cells you're going to get bone to bone
arthritis for which the medical system
has joint replacement surgeries uh
doctors are screaming for a epidemic of
arthritis coming here because there's 80
million baby boomers coming along and
medical doctors have convinced them not
to take vitamins and minerals and as a
result they're all breaking down
and what i tell people alex um is to
cancel your scheduled double knee
replacement our double hip replacement
or your low back surgery give us a give
the alex pack and the extra gluco gel
which is the secret sauce to
supporting and promoting maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc between the
vertebrae give us two months and if you
still think you need your surgery you
can always get the surgery but you can't
always get undead
and so there's always a tremendous risk
with surgery from infection amputations
paralysis i've had one surgery and they
almost killed me in dallas when i was 16
for a broken leg and and i've got a
hernia and i won't go in for surgery
because i'm afraid they'll kill me yeah
yeah you don't want to go in for a
surgery they they are the instrument to
the bad guys you don't want to go in
there believe me believe me
listen they they they tested my blood
i'm going to hold you over for five more
minutes dr wallace you can do it and
then we're going to get bob chapman
because i want to tell this story i'll
start telling it now
my leg gets broken
uh the bones almost sticking out of the
meat they tell me you need a pen
go in and have the surgery after the
surgery they came in they said we tested
your blood you don't have any opiates in
your body you're not a
heroin user there's no drugs in your
blood but
it took nine times the regular amount to
put you under i kept waking up on the
operating table then after that they
didn't put the iv in right i woke up
with blood all over me it was a
nightmare i do not want to ever go in
for surgery again
dr joel wallick is our guest we've
teamed up to bring you infowars
infowarsteam.com
and we're going to he's got free audio
files there we'll be adding video files
there to the site
over the weekend
infowarsteam.com
inviting all my listeners to get
involved i was at 9.95 to sign up then
you get upwards of 30 to 40 percent
discounts on these wonderful vitamin and
mineral and nutrient uh drinks powders
you name it just amazing products i'm
going on the mall next week i've done
the research i've chosen this product
line and what i'm into is what i promote
to you if i'm doing it i tell you about
it it's real simple okay i do what i
believe in i walk the walk ladies and
gentlemen i don't just talk the talk uh
and so you get huge discounts right
there able to buy the products able to
get others signed up and sell it to them
and this is how we defeat the globalist
is through the free market
again liberty is popular the truth and
health is popular and i've done the
analysis the only thing i've got missing
is that i am nutrient deficient i
haven't won a month ago and had my blood
tested okay now going back to dr wallace
we're almost out of time
i was telling that story
and you talk about dead doctors don't
lie that's the name of your radio
program
and that's absolutely accurate uh the
guy that did my surgery was supposedly
this great doctor in dallas he was a
nice guy uh he was a former nfl lineman
and he was a big guy he was only i think
he was less than 50 years old and he did
the surgery and then i went called four
weeks later and said i need to get
scheduled to have the pen taken out i
still got the pen by the way and they
said well the doctors had a huge heart
attack he's down at the coast
uh and he may be retired and i called
back a few months later and said is he
able to remove the pin or i get a new
doctor to do it they said we're sorry
the doctor has died and he wasn't even i
remember wasn't even 50 yet uh so uh you
talk about the statistics and i've seen
them of medical doctors dentists you
name it i mean these people how are we
listening anything they say when they've
got very low life expectancies
you're exactly right alex and this is
why we came up with the alex pack so
that the average american can live to be
well beyond 100 chronologically yet be
biologically 30. the average medical
doctor according to their own research
alex is 56 why would we listen to a
bunch of guys whose average lifespan is
56 how to live to be 100 and they die
from cancer diabetes heart attacks and
strokes
all the things we want to prevent that
are pure why do we go to them as a
madness and so i really really
appreciate our alliance here and your
ability to communicate is just going to
be a nervousness in saving america from
the medical system by getting them on a
healthy program if you don't get sick
you don't need a doctor you don't need a
doctor if you get sick anyway but well
dr wallace that is my plan and that's
why i reached out to you so i did the
research i knew who you were interviewed
before just as a guest and i thought
this is the guy to team up with and i'm
honored to be working with you because
it's very very simple it's just like
fluoride they're now admitting that
sodium fluoride is so toxic to the body
the government had to admit it last week
you know
that's something inside
i'm sorry go ahead it's an insecticide
they use sodium fluoride for
insecticides to kill ants you know fire
ants in texas and africa exactly so i go
with what i know we can do doctor i say
stop drinking fluoride or if i know we
don't have the minerals we need i'm
going to promote it and i'm going to do
it myself i mean it's just all part of
making the right decisions isn't it yeah
absolutely it's kind of a
do-it-yourselfer concept uh americans
are americans because we're independent
uh we don't want the government doing
anything for us except protecting us
from enemies foreign and domestic and in
this case the enemies domestic are the
politicians and the doctors the medical
systems in the pharmaceutical industry
the special interest then and again
that's why they're moving with codex
alimentarius that is in it says codex
elementaries in the food safety act
written by big pharma and big agra they
want to shut down
uh people like dr joel wallach being
able to get us this information and by
the way i'm going whole hog on this i'm
giving this stuff to my parents i'm
giving it to my family i'm not even
going to go out and try to sign him up
i'm going to give it to him first and
see the results they get because i know
they're going to get great results
because i've talked to countless people
over the years about dr wallick dr
wallach oh my gosh i was sick it made me
better and then i did the research on
the minerals i remembered what the vets
i worked for said it makes total sense
let's try it out together infowars team
dot com dr joel wallach of dead doctors
don't lie syndicated uh by the great
michael swirling we'll talk to you again
very very soon sir okay thank you so
much alex god bless you and thank you so
much for the alex pack absolutely that's
the number one thing up there in
infowarsteam.com what dr wallach thinks
you absolutely need it's right there
infowarsteam.com
visit infowars.com and prisonplanet.com
when you're on the site you can also
tune in 24 hours a day to my daily radio
broadcast there's also a free iphone app
to listen to the syndicated radio show
when and where you want